you brought up Kim Kardashian that's how
this whole thing started that's the tip
of the spear yes okay the song with the
deal and broken yeah everyone will look
to her and say well she did a sex tape
now she's a billionaire yeah okay like
the whole family's been manufactured
um I have obviously firsthand my my best
friend is the guy Chris Humphries that
married Kim Kardashian and I was a
groomsman in the wedding I walked Chloe
down the aisle I saw Kendall and Kylie
when they were 15 16 like Bruce was
Bruce when Bruce was Bruce straight up
Bruce I've seen this way back I've seen
this whole thing play out and a lot of
girls are like I remember when you did
it and like all girls love Kim
Kardashian but don't you think that's
the person that started this entire
thing and she married Kanye yeah I don't
think most girls all these girls love
Kim Kardashian I think actually what do
you mean she's the she has more
Instagram followers she is followed and
she is great at marketing herself but I
I do think that there is now a strong
push back to Kardashian culture I think
that's ending is what I'm kind of saying
I don't see it tell me how you're seeing
it changing
um you know I don't think she's as
idolized as she as she was I think that
Kim Kardashian caught that moment of
femininity and sexuality she was the she
is the it girl of what we're talking
about she is the it girl she is the
moment she was talking about sex and
people that that's what their show
what's how it became popular who they
were dating you know who they were
sleeping with she's crying about her sex
tape she's crying about this like she
brought forth the sex culture so she is
the the icon from the moment that we're
talking about but I think we are
actually moving away from it and with
Kim she's a great example
she's got tons of money and she's got
tons of wealth you know
what's her personal life
is that it is it just money and wealth
because she's this is her fourth
marriage that's failed am I correct
marriage well she told me she's gonna
have let's be honest who's going to
marry Kim Kardashian she's she's way too
she's way is that the worst the hot tom
look at this here the highest negative Q
score belongs to Kim Kardashian 71. wow
but I'll give you this argument though
Hollywood report it's not just Kim it's
Kendall it's Kylie it's Chloe okay but
then Kendall I think we'll get married
she's actually kind of abstained from
the what do you mean she's dating that's
the NBA what are you talking about
he's quite like she's quiet though she
doesn't really you know she's quietly
dating after the NBA I'll give you that
okay yeah well said but then this is my
point then they all have kids and you
don't think that their kids are going to
be the most famous girls in the world
Adam where are you going with it this
that she's saying that you think it's
coming to an end well you're saying that
this is going to continue I'm saying
it's one million percent but hear me out
this is this is great so
what is going to happen is with this
this case study again life is about case
studies you're gonna study case studies
you go to Harvard to get an MBA what the
hell you think you do for three years
when you get your MBA 500 case studies
when you go to Harvard for a three-week
program Wharton all you're doing is case
studies four three four years these guys
that go work at Mackenzie Gardner all
these come BCG they only go there
because they have 500 case studies under
their belt that they went through for
whatever Business Degree they got this
is a phenomenal case study for churches
to use this is a phenomenal case study
for schools to use this is a phenomenal
case study for parents to use this is a
phenomenal case study for a lot of
people to use and by the way this case
study is going to inspire some people to
say what you know what you guys are out
of your mind I'm gonna follow what she
did no problem still go out and do it
we've been trying to get people to say
no to drugs for a long time people are
still saying yes to drugs okay you know
what do you do hey did you see how many
people died from fentanyl did you see
how many people die from cocaine and
plain we used to live in Plano
kids went to school everybody before one
moved to Plano Tom's Like Pat let's move
to Plano so I'm like okay so we moved to
Plano
I started saying what are you guys
moving to oh we're moving a plan I know
nothing about Plano Texas when I'm in La
we're living in Granada Hills or where
were we living at we were living in uh
North Porter Ranch or whatever Porter
Ranch it's like oh you're gonna go to
heroin Plano like what type in Plano and
heroin rice
that's always the best time somebody's
like oh you're going there you want to
crack
so stay there tonight yeah go to go okay
look back look at the third story a look
back at the Plano heroin crisis 20 years
20 years ago so I'm like whatever so
kids were dying left and right you get
cheap labor there that's why I remember
you're gonna get so but but the point
I'm trying to make to you is you're
right some people are going to look at
this and say this is how I'm going to
get Fame and some people are going to
look at the sun saying oh my God for the
rest of my life so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]